tonight I've got a recipe challenge
triple whammy I got one over on hard
deep sink early but Julian Clary well
and truly stuck me oh the scores have
won all so now I've got to win right
there's definite something about Mary
she may be queen of the shops but I'm
king of this [ __ ] kitchen let the
battle commence
are you ready what are you cooking I'm
cooking my one pot one day okay well
it's a chorizo stew okay we don't look
like a sausage girl I'm actually have
been in my path chopped up pepper lots
of garlic tomatoes and a little bit of
sherry as well do you have a little
sherry in the afternoon Gordon Mary is
making a really nice amazing series Oh -
with butter beans and tomatoes I'm doing
something a bit more rustic like a sort
of merge a series Oh soup we're gonna
use kidney beans tomatoes garlic basil
red yellow peppers that's a nice sort of
boys that rah rah scares it's a little
fruit fruit it's amazing the boots as
well look at you the thing is though you
do have to look good when you're cooking
as well don't you are you peeling your
tomatoes as well well that's what you
meant to do because people gag on the
skins I've heard potatoes and red onions
starting off let's put off the peppers
and it's really nice rich semi-dried
chorizo you are a style guru you have
any tips for myself 41
yeah middle-aged first thing is doing
this right shirt when you get yours and
you've worked out in those men that like
that you know what so well you know men
that really worked the body out and they
want to show it off for the shirt gets a
bit tight a bit dodgy that yeah that's
not good guys it that's not good the
other things please don't wear too much
black all the time because it looks like
hair dresses you know I've been put a
bit of color in you could take that with
your suntan and your highlight I just
got back from la la are you a natural
ready are you asking me whether my
curtains match the rug yes yes so inside
there now potatoes peppers
serega touches sherry and red onions
come on Gordon I've coked up with you
are you ready people are hungry out
there look right I'm finished might
offer some fresh basil
once the Basil's in bring it up to the
boil and then add my kidney beans that
will give it a little bit of totty
the guy is slacking behind I mean who's
the professional in the kitchen here are
you happy with that I am happy I'm gonna
say they look based him that yeah good
luck yes yeah I lose this challenge okay
I've got a confession to tell you oh
he's done it with the boy I think the
spice is good in it I like the Truitt's
though because it's not too chewy their
kidney veins and Tomas a really good in
it as well it's got a lot more of it
smarter based and it's it's hotter I
thought either beans in this funk
peppers as well feeling confident oh
yeah three two I hate it when he gets
that close it's close
best of three I've gotten by a shop girl
can't [ __ ] believe you
I'll go a confession god I seriously do
not want to see them right